seit Monaten ist die Stimmung in Israel
aufgeheizt die Straßen auf beiden Seiten
des Konfliktes brennen in Judäa und
Samaria wütet der Terrorismus zwischen
März und Mai 2022 wurden auf
israelischen Straßen 19 Zivilisten beim
mörderischen Terroranschlägen von
Palästinensern getötet immer wenn der
terrorzuschlägt kommen Sie die
Spezialkommandos der Armee
Bild-Chef Reporterin Antonia Jamin ist
vor Ort und begleitet golani die
Spezialeinheit der israelischen Armee
die terrorjäger
[Musik]
die terrorjäger an der israelischen
Grenze operieren auf vielfältige Weise
Wachposten rund um die Uhr Geheimdienst
Aktionen verdeckt und präzise
Verhaftungen
undercovereinheiten im Stil von
action-serien wie fauder und natürlich
die Mauer und der Zaun aber sie haben
Schlupflöcher wir sagen wir kriegen euch
überall egal wie egal wo
terrorjäger sind immer im Dienst 24
Stunden 7 Tage die Woche es gibt kaum
eine Nacht in der Kommandant und Team
nicht terrordorfer stürmen stürmen
müssen
wann kommt der große Krieg wenn er da
ist werden wir vorbereitet sein
[Musik]